en fait je suis d'accord si coffre fois
25 minutes à 418 +3 galles 92 / disent
qu'elles veulent
- 10 36 possibilités
le compte est bon j'ai raison
[Musique]
oh
1 2 3 4
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et
vous comprenez pas j'étais obligé mais
pas le choix si je l'avais pas fait
quand même continuer encore et encore
si vous les aviez vu il avait le sourire
à la commet là c'est moi je veux
recommencer depuis le début en fait
qu'est ce qui se passe là j'ai la paix
qui se trouble je disais tout a commencé
la semaine dernière roger métal au clair
les choses tout de suite le jeu sera
temps c'est mon flash bagdad eut fermé
que je parle te plaît donc je disais
mettons clara chose tout de suite le jeu
que je vais tester aujourd'hui n'est pas
vraiment un mauvais gens qui ne s'est
pas un mauvais jeu au sens où on
l'entend d'habitude ce même plutôt un
bon jeu d'ailleurs mais ce jeu est
tellement difficile c'est tellement
galère que même tintin au tibet parfois
ça a l'air plus simple je veux dire
seulement même chef norris ne pourrait
pas finir ce jeu quoi d'ailleurs ce jeu
nous vient d'infogrames la société qui
tenait presque tous les droits sur les
jeunes adapté de bande dessinée comme
tintin astérix marsupilami spirou lucky
luke etc c'était toujours des jeux
magnifiques avec un univers très proche
de la bd mais aussi des jeux ultra dur
qui tenait plus de la punition mentale
que de l'amusement réel
[Musique]
les schtroumpfs sorti en 1994 sur
plusieurs supports moi là je vais tester
la version megadrive
on incarne donc au début je trouve mal
aimé puisque même ses propres codes
veulent le but est et qui doit partir en
mission pour retrouver la schtroumpfette
le niveau est assez facile il faut juste
éviter les seaux d'eau jeté par les
fenêtres
parce que l'on vous tue les jetons sont
vraiment des gros porcs quand même et
aussi il faut éviter seront passés cinq
qui plongent régulièrement du ciel pour
vous tuer pour ça s'amuse en gamme on
envoie en mission pour sauver des postes
est plutôt que se faire griller par tout
le village on te souhaitons bonne chance
non tu te fais agresser par tous tes
amis jusqu'à la sortie
[ __ ] d'ingrats un des objectifs du jeu
c'est de récupérer des feuilles
je suis bon vous êtes probablement le
dealer du village en tout cas il faut
croire que et et pourquoi je peux pas
remonté à temps mais c'est quoi ce piège
là il n'y a pas moyen de remonter quoi
même en appuyant sur le bouton turbo
107e faire sauter plus haut il ya pas
moyen
je suis piégé complètement
mais sérieux mais comment est-ce que je
suis sauce ah ouais ok d'accord un
problème alors je la refais l'entrée est
là la sortie est là mais comment vous
êtes sensé deviner que pour sortir de
l'absence et traverser ce qui apparaît
comme être le décor c'est pas comme s'il
y avait de 10 un panneau où une texture
différente non y'a rien se démerde toi
et vous voyez c'est là toute la
difficulté de ce jeu ce jeu est vicieux
tenez là plus tard ce fameux arbre à
monter des processeurs du jeu se
rappelleront ça a l'air de rien mais
bordel de chiasse cpom ses pommes qui
tombe tout temps sans être visibles
avant et quand c'est pas les pommes
c'est les feuilles mais ça fait des
heures que je marche sur des feuilles
alors pourquoi est ce que j'y ferai
attention et regarder ça là j'y vis la
pomme j'avance pour prendre un item je
fais demi tour je ressors et boum
elle est la première déjà repoussé
[ __ ] de gm
et le pire c'est que c'était à peine le
début de ce côté-là non non non enfin si
ça continue nous disait après ça
n'empêche je dois quand même dire que
l'univers est bien rendu l'aspect bande
dessinée est très bien travaillé et
surtout on retrouve tous les personnages
de la bd
après il ya quand même quelques
incohérences 1 par exemple vous pouvez
tout tuer les mouches les moustiques les
lapins les oiseaux vous pouvez même tuer
les schtroumpfs noirs et par contre pas
question de tuer les papillons créé le
jus raciste en fait le problème d'un
sujet si as exactement ce que j'allais
dire c'est qu'il ya plein de pièges
mortels où tu es obligé de tomber au
moins une fois dedans pour le savoir et
pour pouvoir l'éviter à l'essai suivant
sauf que le problème c'est que l'ebit l
air apparaissent pas ces pervers vicieux
cintrée mais je me demande qui sont les
malades qui ont créé ce jeu pas trop je
voulais aussi un beau du stage c'est
cool ça changera un peu
ok donc je me suis d'accord merci
connard
ah non mais je rêve franchement bon moi
j'ai joué au jeu sur megadrive je
voulais parler rapidement de la musique
quand même plutôt pas mal pour une
megadrive mais j'ai quand même un petit
faible pour la musique sur super nes
notamment sur le bout du stage écouter
ça
[Musique]
globalement c'est un bon jeu old school
c'est de la bonne vieille plate forme
qu'on n'en fait plus c c'est tellement
dur parfois que c'est presque [ __ ]
certain niveau vraiment tu te demandes
comment se débrouiller pour être aussi
vas-y la foudre quoi ou non mais c'est
pas possible que ce soit là par hasard
je veux dire c'est il en calculer
exactement que si tu avances à telles
vitesses a tellement
forcément tu te sens tu tombé pile sur
la gueule sariel haircuts bande de
chacals ils ont mille éclats pile en
dessous de l'item comme certains comme
un con là tu vois bonus tu vas pour
sauter dessus allez bo bo je mange temps
éclair et quand c'est pas les éclairs
séléphanto blackie à chaque fois ils
apparaissent n'a même pas le temps que
te retourner à les bourbes c'était
presque trop flat qui peut même pas se
baisser pour les éviter
alors voila tu recommences tu
recommences tu recommences encore et
encore allez vas-y la jeu c'est bon là
je suis presque à la fin elle sort ne
leur est pas là en fait non [ __ ] là il
m'a bloqué il m'a bloquée je peux plus
passer annoncé montée des eaux et
l'autre imbécile heureux là qui continue
à sourire alors qu'il est mort dix fois
à la partage un peu mon malheur idiot
cataphiles trois secondes tu entends
exactement 3 secondes qu'on effacer ce
[ __ ] de sourire de ta gueule de con ou
je te ferai schickelé les yeux des
orbites et jetant par le crâne je me
demande quels ont été le pourcentage de
gens que la patience d'arriver aussi
loin dans le jeu quand il était gosse
parce que moi en tout cas je l'avais pas
eu quoi ça c'est clair qu'au niveau 9 on
arrivait la grotte et
à temps mais je rêve là c'est le village
qu'on voit sur le côté maintenant il ya
15 mètres entre le village de la grotte
pourquoi tu as fait un détour de 200
kilomètres c'était aux touristes mais
soulage trop fait ya trois mois ce but
rapide et si tu crois pas que tu foules
malgré un peu les derniers niveaux
plus on s'approche de celle gargamel
plus c'est l'enfer alors je vais pas
vous parler de tous les niveaux mais
c'est clair que là pour une fois vous en
avez pour votre fric alors déjà atteint
le niveau avec gallas dans le volcan où
tout est calculé à la seconde près tu
fais la moindre est en deux sauts tu
finis en kebab tu crèves
en fait plus tu avances sur la fin plus
il ya les niveaux qui demande du calme
et du doigté sauf que toi tu as l'air
complètement à bout et du coup tu fais
n'importe quoi il ya ce niveau là qu'est
infernal avec le tronc qui arrêtent pas
de tourner si tu calcules pathé sow avec
un chronomètre tu tombe dans le vide tu
crèves 1-2-3-4 aller 1 2 3 4 5
citez moi un autre jeu qui vous oblige à
faire ça les punaises le niveau des
ronces facile mais stressant
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
allez la phalange te déteste une poutre
dans la tronche auprès de la mine
vous crevez descente de neige un rocher
dans la bouche y at-il dans le cul vous
crevez la montagne vous crevez vous
crevez vous crevez vous crever et quand
vous arrivez à la maison de gargamel là
c'est le best-of
on dirait une combinaison de tous les
trucs vicieux du jeu
elle est déjà pour l'ambiance il devrait
être capable mieux et ça me donne envie
de lire dès que tu sors ton bien que
neuf fois sur dix est atterri sur une
plante carnivore qui comme par hasard
était passé bien en dessous juste à cet
endroit n'était pas visible avant tu lis
a reçu des sommes perdues prophète
les fioles qui dégage des vapeurs
toxiques et que la même couleur que le
décor de fond les mouches qui te tue
alors que deux dixièmes de secondes
avant c'était même pas dans l'écran et
si par miracle je dis bien par miracle
vous faites partie des 0,6 pour cent de
gens qui ont réussi que la patience
d'aller aussi loin alors ce jeu si tu
arrives à passer tout ça gargamel c'est
invraisemblable tellement c'est dur il
faut que le piia plages ses glands sur
le tronc pour le jeter sur gargamel
sorte qu'en faisant ça suffit pas donc
il faut anticiper le retour pour
apprendre d'eux par passage et ça c'est
super dur
[Musique]
tous
oui
[Musique]
j'ai fini mais je trouve j'ai fini les
schtroumpfs
voilà toute cette souffrance pour cet
instant pour libérer la schtroumpfette
la seule femelle du village qu'il va
bientôt faire une petite je trouve pour
nous remercier r1 aller n'ont jamais
mérité une petite trop enflammée d'une
petite bise regarde quoi je pensais
enfin voilà docteur depuis depuis j'ai
fini ce jeu jusqu'au traumatisé je veux
jouer à des jeux trouve partout
vous en pensez quoi en fait vous devrez
écraser vos peuvent regretter et les
amener à détruire votre cocon émotionnel
a mis les votre assentiment du
microphone merci docteur mais non je
sais quoi faire
[Musique]
après
chaud
m
bah
[Applaudissements]
hu
[Musique]